so like going back to your experiences
in school and everything or being
japanese
was like did were you ever like open
about watching anime or did you ever get
bullied for that
um in american school i don't think i
ever really brought it up it's not like
i was trying to keep it a secret yeah
it's not like it doesn't come up in
conversation right right
and i wasn't like these are my interests
but um
oh god i do remember something weird
didn't happen um i had to do
a book report and an autobiography and i
did it on sir arthur conan doyle
because i actually really do like
sherlock holmes but
i already know where this is going but i
also like sherlock holmes because
my favorite anime of all time is
detective kona
it's i grew up with it it's like my baby
okay
now like it's crazy but um i was
obsessed with it and all through my life
i loved it and i loved it so i started
reading like real sherlock holmes
right right and i was like i'm gonna do
my whole book report on this and i got
like
really into it like it was like a 15
minute
presentation to like ran a police stall
yeah like
she was like you already got the a like
shut the [ __ ] up
like [ __ ] we get it you're like an asian
nerd like goddamn sit down
um but that was when in
the whole presentation towards the end i
started talking about detective conan
i had to explain something like about
his name right and other iterations of
his name and i was like
and in japan the most popular anime is
called detective conan
and it's about you know conan doyle but
it's not because
and i had like went on like a really
nerdy tangent you literally did like an
anime analysis video of
why conan is called yeah i did i did i
did
yeah because because um uh ayamagosho
uses
different like specifically different
famous
literature like figures that are like
detective novelists
in his book jackets and they work their
their way into the anime
and i was like so excited about it and i
was like and then like cordelia gray
is hyper i because gray is is high like
it's a it's a tough thing to learn as a
kid you're like man people don't care
about the things that i care about
yeah yeah i mean like i was fired i
didn't get like bullied or anything but
that was what i was like i gotta
turn it down i am weeding people yeah
i gotta shut up right now i got rinsed
for saying i like one piece when i was
like 12.
why why wait but you've never even seen
it no i did when i was a kid oh really
yeah
yeah they were just like why are you
watching cartoons connor we're 11. go
on literally yeah why aren't you my
parents would lie at the time they're
like what are you going to stop watching
cartoons
i'm like 13 i'm like am i supposed to
start what this is awesome though
yeah my parents kept telling me you'll
grow out of this you go out of this here
i am like
about to hit you about to go to
university being like am i going to grow
up
i feel like i'm still really enjoying
this right now a career
was there anything like that in like
american schools or was like they expect
you to like stop
talking about like stuff like that like
you know there definitely was and i
think it was also like
i grew up in like you know late 90s 2000
yeah there was definitely kind of like a
we want to pretend to be older than we
actually
are kind of phenomenon however we also
i have to credit like cartoon network
for this it's a american uh television
station that had this thing called
toonami
it's not like just america yeah um that
was phenomenal and adult swim was
amazing because they would actually
show like cowboy bebop yeah yeah yeah
and
um what was another well they had like a
bunch of weird things like
blue sub six was like outlaw star was
amazing
yeah that was a good one um and then
they did like really
like random things like candidate for
goddess and
stuff like that so they would have
really like triple a
shows and then they'd like interlace
like the cbd
titles that probably were less expensive
right just to like fill that time slot
but
it was it was such a good way to
introduce i think like
this adult theme that is a juxtaposition
to what cartoons are
in the west and i feel like i also then
started like cultivating my like nerd
friends and
uh we all would like watch together and
we'd all we were all gamers so
that kind of like interwoven itself into
like it just weaved itself in perfectly
and i never was like bullied or anything
i'm so jealous because i wish i had
nerd friends just didn't exist
yeah i was growing up in like two
thousands i got sort of [ __ ] for being
nerdy i got
playing video games yeah really yeah
yeah
you know you know maybe i think i just
grew up in like a really cute
well i was all i was i think i've said
this before in the podcast i've always
been envious of the fact that like
america seemed to be way more open to
like nerd culture
and that kind of stuff i think that the
uk is very much
not yeah because it is now it is now but
i feel it definitely depends though on
like the type of friends you had as well